una visita para estrechar lazos frente
al acuerdo de reubicación de migrantes
la secretaria del interior de Reino
Unido suelo bravermann llegó a Ruanda
este sábado para discutir el pacto sobre
el envío de migrantes irregulares que
ambos países firmaron en abril de 2022
durante las primeras horas en quigalí
bravermann se encontró con la secretaria
permanente de exteriores ruandesa y el
alto comisionado británico en la nación
africana pero la reunión importante se
dará con el presidente polkamé 146
millones de dólares a Ruanda a cambio de
trasladar a migrantes en situación de
regularidad a más de 6.400 kilómetros de
Reino Unido todo ello enmarcado en un
plan que contempla la detención y
deportación de personas que ingresen en
el país europeo en pequeñas
embarcaciones a través del Canal de la
Mancha un plan que el gobierno defendió
desde la semana pasada y asegura que no
va a perjudicar a las personas más
vulnerables
tenemos un sólido historial de apoyo a
las víctimas de la esclavitud moderna y
miles de víctimas reciben ayuda cada año
aquí en Reino Unido Y eso no cambiará
mientras frenemos la inmigración ilegal
[Aplausos]
45.000 migrantes irregulares llegaron el
año pasado o sea desbordado nuestro
sistema de asilo el primer vuelo de
deportación de migrantes fue bloqueado
por orden del tribunal europeo de
Derechos Humanos en junio de 2022 pero
la justicia británica dijo en diciembre
que era legal la oposición Busca ahora
apelar la decisión que podría terminar
en la Corte Suprema en abril se
celebrará una vista de apelación en
relación con el plan de Ruanda
esperaremos la sentencia y habría que
preguntar al poder judicial cuando se
cumplirá el calendario respetaremos
cualquier calendario que establezcan los
tribunales
el plan migratorio del Premier británico
una de sus prioridades de mandato ha
despertado el recelo de opositores y
activistas por ser dicen poco ético y